hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American romance drama
film called cashback spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
you know why you clicked this video the
protagonist of the movie is Ben a
baby-faced 25 year old guy who is always
kind and gentle to others one would
assume that he is the ideal friend but
things are the exact opposite Ben is not
exactly a serial killer but he has the
ability to freeze time and do whatever
he wants of course he uses this to strip
women and perform his favorite activity
painting whether it be on the road the
supermarket or even the movies Ben
freezes hot girls and makes their nude
portraits it wasn't always like this
though Ben was a normal guy just like
all of us he had a caring girlfriend and
a promising future and he just dreamed
about painting naked women following
this the movie flashes back to five
weeks earlier where it all went wrong
Ben is seen having an argument with his
girlfriend Susie who calls him a loser
having had enough he breaks up with her
and this enrages Susie even more she
starts throwing objects at him and at
this moment everything turns into slow
motion for Ben in the aftermath of the
breakup Susie quickly moves on and finds
Solace and another guy then notices them
together in the College cafeteria and
becomes distraught hence to distract
himself he joins art classes since Ben
has been interested in making portraits
ever since he was a child he
effortlessly makes beautiful paintings
which surprises even the teacher Ben
specializes in making ultra realistic
human portraits they say that Ben is the
best at painting dong in all the land
however at night Things become extremely
tough for him Ben cannot seem to get
over his breakup as every time he closes
his eyes he sees Susie days pass and he
eventually becomes an insomniac now Ben
cannot fall asleep for even an hour the
memories of his ex-girlfriend are slowly
turning him into a depressed Maniac
overwhelmed by regret and suffering Ben
finally gives Susie a call and pleads
with her to come back he also apologizes
for turning their relationship into a
mess promising to never do it again but
despite Ben stooping so low for her
Susie refuses his request and hangs up
the call this sends been spiraling into
an even deeper abyss of Despair if only
he could just freeze time and look at
boobs over the course of the next few
days he tries his best to pass the time
Ben reads books watches movies and even
goes on solo trips to other cities
however when night falls the insomnia
kicks in making it harder for him to
concentrate on anything else so he
starts going on random tours in the dark
as well one night he heads to a local
supermarket where he notices a job
vacancy announcement for a night shift
guy Ben thinks that this is the perfect
opportunity to pass the time and earn
some money so he immediately applies for
the job the following day he scores an
interview with the manager Jenkins and
eventually lands the job Ben is finally
happy after a long time and he has a gut
feeling that his life is about to change
as Ben becomes accustomed to his new job
he notes how each of his co-workers
handles the art of passing the time
differently the cashier Sharon Pott has
the most unique style she makes sure to
always hide the clock with various
objects she believes that the time will
pass slowly if she looks at it then
there's a mischievous guy called Barry
Brickman who is never serious at work
along with his equally cunning friend
Matt Stevens he plays different pranks
on the female customers like slipping an
adult toy in their bags nothing passes
the time like going to jail some of the
customers are perplexed when they find
it however some of them decide to keep
it the only guy who doesn't seem to care
about the time is their boss Jenkins he
can go on and on about how successful
and Rich he is once he starts with his
egoistical speeches time passes very
fast for him but of all the night shift
employees Ben has the most unusual way
of passing the time in the pangs of his
deep Melancholy Ben disassociates
himself from time and reality in other
words he uses his superpowers to freeze
time and eventually his surroundings so
that he can do whatever he pleases
normally one would run away with money
or do some explicit stuff but Ben just
wants to hone his artistic skills since
he is in awe of the female body he picks
random customers gently disrobes them
begins drawing their portraits Ben has
no lubricious feelings towards them he
just wants to make sure his passion for
art Never Dies
sure Ben once he is done he dresses them
back up and cracks his fingers causing
time to start flowing once again this
has become Ben's life now it is not
something that he can be proud of but at
least he is not that depressed or crazy
anymore slowly but steadily he has
started diverting himself from Susie at
home Ben often hangs out with his best
friend Sean the two have been together
ever since they were kids Sean is the
exact opposite of Ben as all he wants is
to get into a girl's pants whereas Ben
just straight up does it against their
will it is revealed that he has been to
every strip club in the city one night
during his night shift Ben encounters
the cashier Sharon in the locker room he
appears to have a crush on her but he
can't bring himself together to express
it but as they talk the friendly cashier
takes a bite out of his sandwich
shocking him a small piece of pickle
sticks to Sharon's cheek and she
awkwardly tries to wipe it off but to no
avail seeing her struggle Ben steps in
and wipes it off for her creating a very
cheesy moment between the two perhaps
one day I can put my pickle on your face
wrong after a while Sharon decides to
leave and heads towards the door Ben
wants to freeze the moment and live in
it for a week but by the time he comes
to his senses Sharon is already gone
after a while as he is going about his
work Matt suddenly pops up from one of
the Stalls and reveals that he is going
to the movies with Sharon this
devastates Ben and he wonders why he is
so unlucky he then recalls his school
days where he fell in love for the first
time she was the smartest girl in the
class whom everyone used to like one day
she got into an accident and sprained
her arm because of which she had to wear
a heavy cast every day her classmates
used to write encouraging stuff on it to
make her feel better Ben also wanted to
write something but he was too nervous
to even get near her unfortunately his
reluctance cost him the opportunity as a
few days later the girl removed her cast
everyone was happy to see her all
recovered but when they noticed that she
had grown some hair on that arm they
started making fun of her the girl
eventually starts crying and this is
when Ben decides to swoop in he takes
her to a corner and consoles her saying
he will be there with her no matter what
soon the two become good friends and
eventually lovers one day the girl
suddenly approaches Ben and inquires if
he wants to kiss her without thinking
twice he says yes and the two agree to
meet at their favorite spot on the
weekend Ben is elated that he is going
to kiss a girl for the first time he
loses his sleep for the next few days
and when the weekend finally comes he
arrives at the spot early he waits for
the entire day but the girl doesn't
arrive breaking his heart the following
day at school Ben finally learns that
the girl has been relocated to another
city with her parents this is the first
time he felt helpless and depressed back
in the present Jenkins gathers all his
employees and tells them that they are
going to play a friendly football match
with his friends Ben and the others
don't want to play but they have no
other choice during the match the
supermarket team loses heavily as it is
clear that none of them knows how to
play the opposition team ramps up the
score with Goal after goal making it
26-0 when Ben has had enough he freezes
the time and heads to the locker room to
relax suddenly a guy on freezes himself
and runs out this reveals that Ben is
not the only person who has acquired
this ability after a while he heads out
and snaps his fingers allowing time to
revert back to its original form In the
Heat of the Moment Matt kicks the ball
so aimlessly that it ends up hitting
Jenkins in the face he is immediately
rushed to the hospital and all the other
teammates go home leaving Ben and Sharon
alone in the next scene the two stopped
by at a nearby Diner and try to get to
know each other better there Ben gets to
know that she is actually single and
that Matt was just joking about dating
her she then shares her dreams with Ben
and he does the same Sharon says that
she's always wanted to meet a painter
because she imagines that they can see
the true beauty of things even against
the true beauty's will maybe as the two
talk it is clear that they have
chemistry after their unofficial date
Ben walks Sharon home and awkwardly
ruins their First Kiss by pecking her on
the cheeks when she wanted it on the
left Ben was just thinking about the
pickle again the following day a
disfigured Jenkins announces that he is
going to host a party on the occasion of
his birthday Sharon asks Ben if he wants
to come with her as a date and the
latter happily agrees later Jenkins
calls the boys to his office and gives
them separate tasks for his birthday
preparations Ben is assigned with hiring
a stripper to the party although he's
never talked to one in his life he knows
just the person who can help him later
he asks his best buddy Sean for help
promising to take him to the party if
they can get the job done the two then
head to a local Club where Sean uses his
experience and hires a girl for the
party the next morning Ben gets a call
from an anonymous man who claims to be
an art Aficionado he has an art gallery
in the city and wants to have some of
Ben's work in it this Delights the
latter as for the first time in his life
someone has appreciated his art but
unbeknownst to him it turns out to be a
prank call from Barry and Matt that
night Ben gets dressed up for the party
and heads to pick Sharon up as soon as
she opens the door he happily tells her
that a popular organization wants to
display his artwork Sharon
wholeheartedly congratulates him and
soon the two head to the party when they
arrive the party is already underway
Sean John is being rejected by a girl
Matt and Barry are dancing like
sociopaths and Jenkins is on the DJ just
then Barry notices his ex-girlfriend
Susie among the attendees it turns out
she has jenkins's brother's girlfriend
soon the stripper arrives and heats up
the party in particular Sean forms an
instant connection with her meanwhile
Ben heads to the bathroom where he comes
across Susie wasting no time she
expresses that she wants them to
reconcile and become a couple again Ben
of course doesn't want it because he has
already met the love of his life but the
crazy girl keeps on insisting out of the
blue she even kisses him forcefully Ben
immediately pushes her back but when he
turns around he realizes that Sharon
witnessed the whole incident Ben tries
to explain that it's not what it looks
like but the innocent cashier leaves
without hearing a word after a while Ben
goes straight to Sharon's apartment and
tries to explain everything to her but
she is too blinded by her anger when she
starts hurling obscenities Ben gets
upset and leaves due to the breakup he
once again spirals into his world of
depression and insomnia the only thing
he looks forward to is his appointment
with the supposed art gallery company
which had called him in the next scene
the day finally arrives and Ben goes
there with some of his best artwork as
expected the gallery owner denies making
an appointment with him making Ben
realize that he has been pranked but
just as he is about to leave the owner
notices some of his sketches of Sharon
and asks to have a look unsurprisingly
he likes them and Ben is offered a night
to display his work in the gallery a few
days later Sharon receives an official
invitation to Ben's art display although
she is angry with him she still decides
to visit the gallery when Sharon arrives
there she is taken aback to see that the
artwork there is about her it turns out
Ben stopped making portraits of other
women and he used all of his time on
Sharon she was the love of his life and
he could not stare at any other woman
other than her but how does he know
exactly what my nipples are shaped like
meanwhile Sharon and Ben finally meet
the latter tries to explain what
happened on the party night but Sharon
says that he doesn't have to she has now
realized how much he loves her just by
looking at his paintings with this the
the two get closer and share a romantic
kiss right in the middle of the art
gallery room in the final scene Ben uses
his powers and freezes everything
however this time even Sharon can move
in the Frozen world the two then go out
into the snow where millions of
snowflakes are suspended in the air at
last the lovebirds kiss once more hence
ending the movie on a happy note
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching